[Music]
the adaptive joker hypothesis
what is that
that is the name i gave to
to my theory on play behavior basically
i did for my masters and for my phd i
studied play behavior
and
the question you ask yourself as a as a
revolutionary biologist as mythology is
that what's the function of behavior and
so play has typically
and continues to very rightly thought as
developmental scaffolding namely
something a behavior that is expensive
and risky but young animals do
in order to build up
the organism so play prepares you for
the future play train skills
all of that is true play fighting and
leopards or something like that play
fighting in leopards
wordplay in young humans and as a rule
of thumb you will observe how the young
of a certain species play and you can
have inferences on you know what they do
as adults and you know place training
for adulthood so all of that is true
but if you think of the word scaffolding
to me was puzzling because it's like
developmental scaffolding so maybe it's
because i come from a family of
architects but i keep thinking
a scaffold is something that is used to
build a building and then when the
building is done you remove the scaffold
i the scuffle is useless it's just
aiding you in constructing something and
when the thing the building is ready you
take the scaffold away
and
the object is the thing i the building
that is ready and if play is a scaffold
for building adult organisms it means
that play should finish when somatic
growth finishes
i you turn 17 18 you stop playing
i think again this is roughly true in
many species
it's not very common that adult
animals
play
but if you start looking around again
with this
question of like
hon ask the question and
then tell me which animals play as
adults
and so what would come to mind let me
ask you that question
which animals played
dolphins would come to mind yeah
although i do say
what was that second one humans
oh i thought you said cubans i was like
maybe cubans yeah sure
they do like salsa i mean that kind of
looks like damn i mean that's that's
that's playful yes yeah great music
uh i'm sitting in austin texas there are
actually a lot of
a lot of amazing cubans here which is
why maybe that's like talking about the
sort of attention bias
but
humans
although
i mean
one would need to i think perhaps take a
second to define play
so if play is not this
i can't remember the the exact modifier
used but the scaffolding if it is not
that
then then what is play right it seems
like something that doesn't serve an
obvious
functional purpose
that entails some degree of positive
emotional display i mean because i don't
know if that's me struggling for a
definition but no you're correct how
would you define it we're mixing two
definitions there so i want to make a
distinction when you ask this question
tim bergen another famous ethologist
defined the four questions
when you think about a behavior what
why and from where so
the question i was asking is what's the
evolutionary function of the behavior
which is different from defining it how
does it look today okay right sure so if
you want to define it and when you
observe something and you want to study
it you need to define it
how does it look today so you can define
it broadly as
a behavior that appears cooperative in
the sense that
it doesn't look
forced animals are not doing it under
constrained duress or obvious aggression
and there might be a sense of enjoyment
and it appears not having an obvious
purpose it has repetitive elements but
these repetitive elements also have
variation
and so the element of enjoyment and
recombination of elements is part of it
okay okay
yeah that makes sense and so appearing
to having fun but of course you know
that's easy when you look at humans but
like you look at reptiles and it's like
how do you notice snake is having fun
he's like well
yeah i don't have
deep exposure to a lot of animals i
would say canids certainly you see
something resembling play in dogs in
fox
etc yeah wolves certainly
you know cats i mean there seems to be
some type of
tailing off in almost every species i
think of in terms of play i mean maybe
you have like old old
dudes you know like seven-year-old
humans playing chess and
parks and so on but the types of play
change certainly over time you know one
of the coolest things i've ever seen
was video captured by a trail camera in
the us of a coyote
playing with
i mean i it certainly looked like play
with a badger yes i remember that
they hunt together
and it was jumping around wagging its
tail dropping into kind of this downward
dog like play position just as a
domestic dog domesticated dog would
and i don't want to take us too far off
track but this
this is directly mapping from some
northern american
indian
mythologies or what were thought to be
mythologies that had largely never been
observed by sort of western
field biologists and it was kind of
thought to be this nonsensical
mythology and then lo and behold
it's actually right there in front of
you on camera it's pretty cool but i i'd
never
observed i don't think i'd observed much
in terms of
non-combative inter-species
play in that way right like a cat
playing with a mouse but the mouse isn't
having a great time sure no that that
would be there's one animal there having
fun and playing the other one is not
so yeah yeah very clearly okay so so
those are a few examples that come to
mind yeah what other examples come to
mind for you it's a family of corvids so
ravens crows
are
very playful birds parrots as well
it's not a coincidence if you look at
brain to body size ratio both these
groups of birds by namely parrots and
corvettes are kind of equivalent if you
will
two citations on great apes in their
their big brains cetaceans including
dolphins yeah dolphins whales so in that
these are animals that
don't think of immediate
genealogical relationships but think of
the niche again what niche what what do
these animals have in common they are
highly social they live in complex
societies they have to deal with
complexity they tend to be long-lived
and just if you add the dimension of
time if you're social and are long-lived
it means you have to deal with
uncertainty
because who's your friend will it be
your friend two weeks from now you
haven't seen them with whom to cooperate
with whom not to cooperate
social life is complex
and so all of these groups of animals
have these things and common elephants
is another group of animals that also
play and they
fall in this broad group of
generally speaking large brain
intelligent animals that live for a long
time they are
very innovative but also extremely
social so you have a relationship
between sociality and intelligence and i
think the third element there is that
play
when it's possible because now we get
into the socioecology of play play is
not always possible
particularly for adults many things need
to happen for play to make sense play
has costs and risks
and is more important for the young so
the scaffolding is still true
you